nichts für die menschen überall so oft
und so nahe zueinander wie ihr glaube
ganz gleich ob kirche tempel oder
moschee
die religion ist religionsgemeinschaft
und gemeinschaft ist quatsch schwer
wir haben überall gefragt wie das wohl
geht mit dem gebet und der gemeinde und
weil wir selbst nicht reisen dürfen
haben wir filmen lassen von denen dies
betrifft aus thailand und aus texas aus
polen istanbul und kairo kamen bilder
und antworten
und die lauten so wenn sich die
klosterschüler für ihre mahlzeiten
anstellen da neuerdings nur noch mit
sicherheitsabstand und schutzausrüstung
denn auch in thailand 30.000 tempeln hat
sich vieles verändert so ich nehme die
maske jetzt mal ab sonst was steht man
mich ja gar nicht hier ist ja auch sonst
keiner
die müssen wir also nun immer tragen
zumindest aber diese gesichts schirme
und manchmal sogar handschuhe mönch
frahm aha wird die jump an hat uns diese
bilder geschickt aus dem molli locker
jahr am tempel in bangkok wo mönche seit
300 jahren die klassischen texte
studieren
aber jetzt wo sich alles um cupid 19
dreht muss fremmer boutique sei der
lehrer für alt indisch neben den alten
schriften auch neue vorschriften
beachten
die tische in unseren klassenzimmern
müssen ein meter fünfzig abstand
voneinander haben
außerdem herrscht natürlich auch im
unterricht besagte masken oder schirm
pflicht und davor muss sich jeder
gründlich die hände
thailand steht vergleichsweise gut da
mit nur 3000 infektionen und weniger als
60 todesopfern liegt vielleicht auch an
den strengen abstands und hygiene regeln
die die regierung verhängt hat auch für
das tempel studium aber die neuen
hygienebestimmungen machen alles
schwieriger ich kann die gesichter
meiner studenten gar nicht mehr erkennen
und sie verstehen mich nicht so gut wenn
ich die maske tragen und das atmen fällt
damit auch selbst schwer
thailands mönche leben von almosen die
sie jeden tag in der nachbarschaft
sammeln
doch wegen der ausgangssperre sind nun
viele von der versorgung abgeschnitten
die molli lok jahr an tempel aber haben
sie glück nebenan ist eine kaserne der
seestreitkräfte und die marine kantine
kocht netterweise für sie mit deswegen
müssen sie hier anders als viele andere
mönche und klosterschüler keinen hunger
leiden aber es leidet die gemeinschaft
der zusammenhalt geht mehr und mehr
verloren
früher haben wir in unserem tempel immer
besonderen wert auf das gemeinsame essen
gelegt nun dürfen wir nicht mehr
zusammen sitzen und manche nehmen ihr
essen und ziehen sich ganz zurück als
sei das studium der alten schriften
nicht schwierig genug müssen die schüler
nun auch noch lernen allein zu sein
ich bin james joyce und ich bin pastorin
der ersten battiston gemeinde in
farmville texas eine autostunde von
dallas 1849 von zwiebel fahrern
gegründet davon zeugt die alte
verladestation farmers will ist selbst
für amerikas bibel gürtel extrem
gottesfürchtig es hat ein dutzend
kirchen für 3000 einwohner
[Musik]
und da hinten am ende der straße das ist
die first baptist church und ihre
nebengebäude verwaltungstrakt und
sporthalle aber seit mitte märz der
lockdown kam ist es auch hier ruhig
geworden was pastor cheeseman aber keine
bange macht
[Musik]
in dieser zeit habe ich versucht den
menschen den weg zu jesus zu weisen und
sie dazu zu bringen ihm zu vertrauen
denn er wird uns nie enttäuscht
psalm 46 sagt gott ist unsere zuversicht
und stärke
darum fürchten wir uns nicht wenn gleich
die welt unterging und die berge mitten
uns mehr senken als gläubiger christ
habe ich keinen grund angst zu haben
im kleinen farmers will gab es 17 corona
fälle im ganzen county über 1000 und 30
patienten sind gestorben
da wundert es nicht dass sie es mit dem
desinfizieren sehr genau nehmen damit
sich die gläubigen nicht zu nahe kommen
haben sie die stühle in der sporthalle
aufgebaut falls bei 180
sicherheitsabstand nicht mehr alle in
die kirche passen sollten
es gab nämlich die ersten lockerungen
nun darf sich die gemeinde am
sonntagmorgen wieder zum gottesdienst
versammeln
allerdings nur unter auflagen
ich lächele
jeder wird zu seinem platz geleitet nur
familien dürfen zusammensitzen
körperkontakt händeschütteln umarmen gar
verboten
wer gefährdet ist soll lieber daheim
bleiben und den gottesdienst weiterhin
im internet verfolgen denn er wird auch
online übertragen
und zwar seit dem 15 märz angefangen
haben wir mit einer einfachen webcam die
wir auf vimeo bedient haben
in der zweiten woche hatten wir dann
zwei iphones im einsatz und dann haben
wir diese richtig tolle drei kamera
video anlage eingebaut die ihr da oben
an der wand sehen könnt
countdown zur taufe denn wieder kann
chef pastor barbara ein neues mitglied
in der gemeinde begrüßen
der mann der stunde der junge der
gekommen ist um sich heute taufen zu
lassen steht schon bereit
komm doch mal her
das ist matt hughes ist der jesus
angenommen und die frohe botschaft
verstanden wenn er nicht gerade taufen
vornimmt hält sich pastor bad
vorbildlich an abstandsregeln und
vereinzelung 's gebot aber auch ihm
macht die korona pandemie keine angst
[Applaus]
das ist ja nicht die erste pandemie für
die christliche kirche auch nicht die
erste zeit der prüfungen der
schwierigkeiten oder des
wirtschaftlichen abschwungs oder was
auch immer
die kirche hat all das schon erlebt wir
können der gleichen mit unserem glauben
bewältigen und so schreiten wir voran
und schon stimmt pastor james mit seiner
mandoline wieder ein neues lied an aus
dunkelster nacht hast du uns in ein
strahlendes licht gerufen sinkt er
ja
überhaupt wird viel gesungen bei den
christen in texas wenn auch der
kirchenchor im moment zwangspause hat
[Musik]
wegen corona können wir zurzeit unsere
regulären chorproben nicht abhalten und
haben deshalb auch zoom geübt aber heute
abend treffen wir uns zur karawane alle
haben sie schon hinter mir auf dem
parkplatz versammelt mit der erfahren
sie über land um die aufzumuntern die
krankheitshalber in quarantäne bleiben
müssen
15 fahrzeuge zählt pastor james und
schon wird der pool zur bühne
und zum clown schmettert der chor und
vertreibt die einsamkeit
[Musik]
während sie weit entfernt in der alten
welt ganz neue lieder anstimmen
kattowitz ist die heimat von polens
führender ministranten boygroup sechs
dem hip hop zugewandte messdiener
verbinden liturgie und punchline jedoch
hat die pandemie sie wie so viele
musiker tragisch als tonstudio gefesselt
und das wohl doch ausgerechnet jetzt die
rapper karriere gerade so richtig ins
rollen kommen wollte wir mussten viele
konzerte absagen und alle unsere pläne
erst mal auf eis legen
wenigstens können wir jetzt wieder aus
dem haus gehe jedenfalls wenn wir masken
tragen auf ihre frommen sprechgesänge
muss die fangemeinde natürlich auch im
lockdown nicht verzichten die verbreiten
sie im netz zum beispiel den song über
glück und freuden des messdiener
dienstes den sie so schmerzlich
vermissen ministranten musiklabel lernen
sie sich etwas spärlich und sind in
polen längst mehrfache klick millionäre
[Musik]
die bibelstunden und gesprächskreise
fehlen uns sehr die gibt es nur im
internet
und außerdem dürfen nur volljährige
ministranten am gottesdienst teilnehmen
aber wir hoffen dass sich die lage bald
wieder normalisieren
[Musik]
bis dahin bleiben sie halt zu haus wie
sie in ihrer villa chaparro die
empfehlen mit maske liefert pizza und
klopapier
[Musik]
mit einer guten prise wehmut denken
viele in istanbul wohl gerade an frühere
jahre als es abend sind den straßen
ihrer stadt oft so aussah es ist nämlich
ramadan in der islamischen welt und das
fastenbrechen nach sonnenuntergang ist
das tägliche glückserlebnis für groß und
klein für alt und jung aber im jahr der
pandemie bleiben die gassen abends leer
und die maschinen auch was aber nicht
heißt dass der fastenmonat der vor allem
auch eine zeit der wohltätigkeit ist
ausfallen müsste
in seiner dede man moschee sorgt imam
abdul damit dafür dass milde gaben auch
dort ankommen wo sie gebraucht werden
hier im vorraum der moschee sind die
regale in denen normalerweise die
gläubigen vor dem gebet ihre schuhe
abstellen können wir haben nun alles
desinfiziert und lagern hier die
lebensmittel und andere sachen die uns
spender überlassen haben
da sind zum beispiel suppen oder auch
konserven auch speiseöl und alle
möglichen anderen nahrungsmittel mit
offiziell über 150.000 infizierten und
über 4000 todesfällen ist die türkei vom
virus schwer betroffen
ausgangssperren werden verhängt und dann
wieder aufgehoben keiner weiß woran er
ist nur die armen wissen dass es sie wie
immer schlimmer trifft aber sie finden
ein wenig trost und unterstützung in den
regalen des imam das hier ist der
innenraum der moschee wo wir
normalerweise unsere gebete verrichten
nun ist es ein warenlager hier sehen sie
die pakete die gespendet werden
zum beispiel dies hier eine anonyme gabe
[Musik]
die hier hat der spender persönlich
vorbeigebracht
hier ist eine spende von putzmitteln
hygieneartikeln
dank dieser großzügigkeit können wir
unsere regale immer wieder auffüllen und
so kommt am bosporus wenigstens ein
bisschen ramadan stimmung auf anders als
in kairo dass die straßen tagsüber
erstaunlich leer sind und die große
stadt träge und manchmal wie betäubt das
ist normal im fastenmonat sagt sheikh
hassan der das gut kennt aber sagt er
noch nie habe ich erlebt dass die
moscheen geschlossen waren
wir haben stürme überstanden und
erdbeben und nie waren die moscheen zu
im gegenteil das waren doch die momente
als die menschen gottes nähe suchten
manche bleiben ängstlich zu hause andere
glauben nicht dass das virus ihnen
schaden kann sagt der shake und prediger
der seine moschee nicht mehr öffnen darf
und schlimmes für die gesellschaft
befürchtet vor allem für die jugend
früher sind auch die jungen leute in die
moschee gegangen und haben still ihre
gebete verrichtet und zugehört aber
jetzt lungen viele auf der straße herum
lachen und machen allerlei unfug und
vielleicht machen sie sogar richtig
ärger
sturm sind die minarette das gemeinsame
fastenbrechen fällt aus und jeder betet
still für sich allein aber jeder fügt
sich den anordnungen der regierung auch
schon der wäscherei besitzer auch wenn
es weh tut
ich musste mitarbeiter entlassen wir
haben kaum noch etwas zu tun und ihr
mittagsgebet haben sie in die stille
gasse hinter der wäscherei verlegt auf
desinfizierte teppiche mit corona prüft
gott unseren glauben vermutet der shake
und vielleicht sagt er vielleicht habe
das alles ja auch was gutes
dass die menschen nun weniger raus gehen
und deshalb auch weniger sündigen